franchement vraiment trop cher c'est
abusé s'amuse à regarder le prix gasoil
1 à 71
franchement c'est abusé ben écoutez on
travaille pour ça on peut être que ça
c'est trop
mais voilà
ça pèse beaucoup ça que je marche à pied
des fois obligé sinon ça un peu trop
cher demain il devrait aider la
population
il est très cher et je sais que l'état
se prend 80 centimes minimum dessus donc
ça serait bien qu'ils diminuent un petit
peu les taxant un peu trop zep trop
élevé serait bien je suis à 70 euros là
le plein pour une micra moteur dci ouais
c'est un petit un petit bout d'os un
petit moteur et il ya quoi il ya trois
mois de ça j'ai une autre voiture une
grosse mercedes un gros moteur j'avais
pour le même prix j'avais un plan
complet pour un gros gros moteur voyez
il ya une grosse grosse différence c'est
certain
c'est sûr que là avec ce qui se passe ça
peut que bien qu il peut y avoir des
manifestations
si déjà avant c'était moins cher et
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas ça à 30
centimes en plus forcément
ça va forcément donner lieu à des
manifestations et des rassemblements je
suis
[Musique]